bien sûr nous sommes dans la majorité
mais dans celle ci il y a deux courants
deux sensibilités deux approches de la
vie de la société du pouvoir de l'avenir
de notre pays
il ya ceux qui veulent protéger et
préserver l'ordre existant voir
reconstituer je ne sais quelle ombre
anciens et il y a ceux qui veulent
ouvrir les portes de la société de
demain vers l'avenir il y a ceux qui
privilégient la tradition et il ya ceux
qui choisissent la modernité et le
changement
elia les conservateurs et ils y allaient
progresser vous êtes les progressistes
je vais vous donner des exemples simples
la majorité bien entendu comme la
majorité des français adhèrent à
l'économie de marché mais nous nous
sommes décidés à refuser la montée des
injustices sociales
nous sommes décidés à ne pas accepter
les inégalités qui s'accroissent nous
demandons davantage de régulation pour
que l'économie soit vraiment au service
des hommes des femmes des familles et
non pas l' inverse
nous sommes aussi attachée que quiconque
à la sécurité et à l'ordre
nous ne croyons pas néanmoins que l'or
vient seulement de la loi de la
répression de la police même si les uns
et les autres la loi la répression et la
police sont nécessaires nous pensons
aussi qu'il faut une autre approche
perdre la loi perben
1 la loi perben 2 la loi hortefeux
1 la loi hortefeux de la loi guéant 1 et
bientôt la loi guéant deux sûrement ça
n'est pas à coup de lois successives que
l'on gagne plus de sécurité
ça n'est pas à coup de lois suspects
issus successives que l'on peut
convaincre il faut aussi d'autres
convictions
d'autres approches d'autres prise de
conscience et d'autres initiatives
nous croyons aux réformes nécessaires
c'est même pour cela que nous avons
soutenu nicolas sarkozy en 2007 pour
qu'il soit président mais nous croyons
que les vraies réformes ne se conçoivent
line se décide dans la solitude du chef
il y faut un dialogue avec la société un
dialogue approfondi
comme l'a montré jean louis borloo dans
le grenelle 1 qui l'a si magnifiquement
réussie d'où nos déceptions déception
lorsque la réforme des retraites si
importante a été expédié sans dialogues
ray
déception quand la réforme territoriale
a été bâclée sans discussion avec les
élus déception devant l'agitation
fiscale permanente déception devant la
jeunesse de france abandonnée à
elle-même 8% de chômage des jeunes en
2025 pour cent aujourd'hui qui peut
l'accepter
voilà pourquoi mes chers amis il faut se
réjouir que nous créions ensemble
l'alliance il y a une grande urgence
notre famille politique
car nous sommes une famille politique
ces sentiers abandonné pendant toutes
ces années a elle même
il ya une grande attente silencieuse
souvent mais profonde et réelle de la
nation dans le peuple
berne ou mais je vais vous dire il faut
en accepter toutes les conséquences je
me permets de dire humblement que je
peux le dire d'autant mieux que moi je
suis le seul à avoir quitté l'ump pour
rejoindre notre famille et donc voilà
voilà ce que ça signifie créer un parti
nouveau ça veut dire un groupe à
l'assemblée nationale
ça veut dire des candidatures à toutes
les élections des candidatures communes
ça veut dire une stratégie politique
élaborée mise en oeuvre ensemble par
quatre stratégies pour quatre
coprésidents une stratégie pour tous il
seul ça veut dire une organisation
moderne dans nos territoires et dans nos
départements
une organisation comme on les fait dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui une organisation
en réseau s'agit pas de dix autres nos
chapelles comme vous j'aime bien la
mienne mais il s'agit d'organiser la
procession commune de toutes nos
convictions avec quelques repères
simples ils pourront jouer collectif
il faut avoir de la patience et de la
bienveillance entre nous et il nous faut
des objectifs parce que notre objectif
mes chers amis c'est la conquête la
conquête des départements la conquête
des régions la conquête des villes et la
conquête de la présidence de la
république
voilà notre grand projet politique pour
la décennie qui vient
et je veux m'adresser maintenant
directement et personnellement devant
vous tous à jean louis borloo
la réussite de notre projet passe par
l'élection présidentielle l'alliance
l'alliance aujourd'hui avec vous tous
c'est toi qui l'a voulu
c'est toi qui en a tracé le cadre c'est
toi qui a le mérite d'avoir rassemblé ce
qu'ils étaient et par cette fête
d'aujourd'hui s'est aussitôt succès mais
maintenant
l'alliance se tourner vers toi il faut
déchirer le rideau pour dire toute la
vérité
nous voulons entrer dans la campagne
présidentielle
mon cher jean loup et il ya de
l'impatience fixe ton calendrier mais
prend les commandes sans trop
embarrassée prolé maintenant est
définitivement
notre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
c'est toi l'esprit d'équipé ça compte
hervé morin que je salue mon ami bockel
que je salue et tous les autres jean
christophe lagarde
sauvadet yves lachaud laurent hénart et
tout ce que je ne salue pas mais pour
lesquels mon amitié va vers eux je leur
dis qu'on a besoin d'être ensemble
mais c'est jean louis borloo qui est en
situation
ainsi l avis
il y à 35 ans c'était valéry giscard
d'estaing me permettrai vous de vous
dire de vous le dire aujourd'hui c'est
jean louis borloo c'est la même
intelligence de son temps c'est la même
modernité c'est la même énergie caché
sous un style très personnel et c'est la
même hostilité du milieu rpr que nous
connaissons bien mais mon cher jean loup
et nous voulons faire campagne
pas simplement pour faire de la
figuration pas seulement pour faire
gagner les autres mais pour gagner nous
mêmes et gagner c'est possible mes chers
amis gagner c'est possible mes chers
amis je vous le redis gagner c'est
possible
les français veulent le changement et ne
reconduirons pas les mêmes
les français se méfient de la gauche
nous sommes la solution nous sommes
l'espoir ici 40 ans après mitterrand et
par 40 degrés à l'ombre
un nouvel espoir est né il s'appelle
borloo borloo président
chers amis à présent j'accueille à la
tribune
quelqu'un qui n'était pas là il ya 40
ans parce qu'il est trop jeune mais qui
vient de lagos qui a essayé d'en faire
de faire entendre raison à gauche
pendant des années et qui finalement
s'est dit qu'il était bien mieux dans
notre famille politique à tous celle des
gens raisonnables et qu'ils aient envie
d'agir
je vous demande d'accueillir jean marie
bockel président de la gauche moderne
mes chers les chers amis de de
l'alliance cher jean christophe schaerer
hervé chevreau qui nous accueillait qui
nous accueille chez toi il ya il ya 40
ans ici à epinay quasiment jour pour
jour la vie politique française
connaissait en effet un tournant
important
la gauche s'était divisée elle se
rassembler elle n'avait pas de chef elle
s'en donnait 1
elle était exclu au pouvoir depuis 1958
et elle renouer avec l'esprit de
conquête
seulement il a fallu dix ans à françois
mitterrand pour l'emporter pour aller à
la victoire et nous mes chers amis nous
avons dis moi dis moi pour parler aux
français
dix mois pour convaincre 10 mois pour
apporter à chacun d'entre vous pour
apporter à la france toute entière
la victoire car mes chers amis la france
nous l'aimons nous l'aimons plus que
tout c'est elle que nous voulons servir
et c'est pour elles que nous voulons
nous battre et c'est pour elles que nous
sommes rassemblés aujourd'hui si
nombreux à epinay sur seine
nous venons d'horizons différents du
centre de droite et de gauche
il y a des libéraux des écologistes des
sociaux démocrates des radicaux des
démocrates-chrétiens et cette diversité
mes chers amis elle est notre force et
le parti que nous créons ce n'est pas un
parti comme un autre
ne créons pas aujourd'hui un de ces
parti monolithique
aucune tête ne dépasse sauf celle du
chef
l'alliance mes chers amis c'est la
diversité des talents d intelligence et
d expérience ce qui nous anime
ce n'est pas l'esprit de parti si cet
esprit là cet esprit qui reviennent
aujourd'hui nos institutions avaient
jamais guider notre action nous ne
serions pas là nous serions ailleurs
chacun de notre côté
refusant de nous parler campant sur nos
positions respectives et cherchant à
satisfaire nos propres ambitions
si nous sommes ensemble c'est que nous
avons choisi une bonne fois pour toutes
de tourner le dos à cette conception la
de la politique
si nous sommes ensemble c'est parce que
nous avons choisi l'indépendance
nous n'avons qu'une seule ambition
servir la république
alors ne nous y trompons pas la
république c'est tout ce qui nous reste
tout ce qui reste aux français pour s'en
sortir et les français eux le savent
oui nous avons ensemble à refonder la
république une république sociale une
république écologistes une république de
l'audace de l'imagination la république
c'est une idée neuve permanente
l'alliance mes chers amis ça n'est pas
un parti comme les autres
ce n'est pas le parti de la surenchère
démagogique
nous respectons trop les français pour
leur tenir ce genre de discours
les français il exige de nous la vérité
et nous allons leur dire nous sommes le
parti de la raison et c'est pourquoi
nous avons choisi la vérité nous
rejetons les solutions toutes faites des
idées simplistes la démagogie à la
petite semaine qui est trop souvent
devenues le lot commun de la vie
politique française nous nous voulons
réconcilier les français avec la
politique
nous voulons mettre la politique au
service de tous les français
et bien la politique elle ne peut être
utile aux français qu'en regardant la
réalité en face en montrant et en
regardant le monde tel qu'il est pas on
se ferment les yeux
ni en alimentant les illusions et je
veux dire puisque nous sommes à epinay à
mes amis de gauche ceux qui voient le
parti socialiste refusé de devenir un
grand parti responsable
à l'image des autres partis de la gauche
européenne je veux leur dire une fois de
plus rejoignez nous car les valeurs
humanistes dans lesquels ils se
reconnaissent l'égalité la justice
sociale la fraternité républicaine
l'idéal européen
toutes ces valeurs que nous partageons
c'est ici qu'elle soit aujourd'hui ses
valeurs et je leur dis vraiment devant
ces primaires socialistes qui
départageront des candidats pensent sur
la même chose dix ans la même chose ne
propose rien ce n'est pas là que ça se
passe
c'est chez nous que ça se passe
aujourd'hui pour vous la social
démocratie que vous appeler de leurs
voeux
c'est aussi ici dans la diversité de nos
sensibilités qu'elle s'invente alors je
veux leur dire à mes amis de gauche
venez venez comme vous êtes venez avec
vos idées avec vos convictions avec vos
références
venez rejoindre l'alliance vim
dis-moi dis-moi nous avons dit - mes
chers amis pour donner le meilleur de
nous mêmes au pays
nous avons dix mois pour donner le
meilleur d'entre nous à la république
alors chers hervé morin cher hervé de
charette cher rama yade et tous les
autres et surtout si vous le permettez
cher jean louis borloo c'était une bonne
idée de nous retrouver ici à epinay on
est loin des grands meetings des partis
politiques
cela donne sa vraie couleur à l'alliance
nous sommes pas un parti comme les
autres pour un peu mes chers amis je
vous vois au soleil avec vos cannes elle
tient pour un peu on se croirait même en
vacances tu partagent mon opinion jean
louis alors oui profites en profites en
bien parce que cette année les vacances
seront courtes
tu as attendu par les français ici et
maintenant
tuer au travail nous sommes au travail
avec toi l'atmosphère est champêtre
estivale une soupe studio studieux
engagé au travail nous sommes au travail
pour nous organiser pour réfléchir pour
partir à la conquête de chaque français
de chaque française
oui jean louis tu as un grand rendez
vous avec les français
ils t'attendent ils ont besoin de toi et
nous nous sommes avec toi
nous sommes avec toi car nous savons une
chose
cher jean lui dans dix mois nous
l'espérons tous nous le voulons tous tu
nous conduira à la victoire
et maintenant mesdames et messieurs je
vous demande d'accueillir celui qui avec
une partie des parlementaires qui sont
ici présents et que je veux remercier
j'aperçois fille l'effigié olivier jardé
j'ai vu tout à l'heure charles amédée de
courson en 2007 et sid est de créer un
nouveau parti pour rester indépendant et
permettre en réalité nos retrouvailles
aujourd'hui je vous demande d'accueillir
hervé morin ancien ministre de la
défense président du nouveau centre est
cher ami tout d'abord merci à hervé
chevreau
merci à jean christophe et a aidé les
merci à toutes celles et tous ceux qui
ont participé à l'organisation de cette
réunion
c'est un énorme travail et mes premières
pensées vont pour celles et ceux qui
depuis vit jour on bossait ardemment
pour l'organisation de cette journée
merci à vous toutes et à vous tous chers
amis pourquoi sommes nous là qu'allons
nous faire de notre unité et comment
allons nous faire
c'est un joli plan de discours est bien
pour vous dire la vérité ce plan ce
n'est pas le mien
non en fait c'est celui du discours de
françois mitterrand ici à epinay il y à
40 ans presque jour pour jour
rassurez vous je ne suis pas candidat
aux primaires du parti socialiste
mais si vous en êtes d'accord je vais
quand même garder ce plan de discours
car il me paraît tout à fait adapté à
notre situation actuelle alors première
question pourquoi sommes nous là il ya
bien sûr le plaisir de nous retrouver
ensemble beaucoup de visages amis mais
la réponse essentielle n'est pas là nous
sommes là parce que nous voulons
adresser un message aux français et leur
dire que le centre portera un projet
alternatif au parti socialiste et à
l'ump aux prochaines élections
présidentielles et en prochaines
élections législatives
oui un message que nous d'eux hervé sont
tout d'abord à toutes celles et à tous
ceux qui ont annoncé un peu vite la mort
du centre un message à celui qui nous a
souvent dit que le centre n'existait pas
un message à tous ceux qui clamaient que
nos divisions était trop forte
un message à tous ceux qui affirmaient
que nos idées n'avait plus d'avenir
parce qu'elle avait été absorbée par les
autres un message donc à tous ceux qui
nous ont enterré un peu vite et qu'ils
nous voient aujourd'hui rassembler au
delà de nos personnes au delà de nos
tendances et au delà de nos partis nous
leur montrons vous leur montrez par
votre seule présence qu'ils se sont
trompés sur toute la ligne car notre
rassembler rassemblement c'est aussi un
magnifique message en direction de ces
millions de français qui à chaque
élection présidentielle depuis 1965 ont
porté leurs suffrages vers un candidat
du centre
je leur dis qu'en 2012 aussi ils
pourront faire ce choix que le centre
aura un candidat et que rien
rien ni personne ne pourra nous faire
changer d'avis
n'en déplaise à nos adversaires le
centre ça n'est pas un accident
historique
le centre c'est la confluence de
plusieurs courants de pensée une réalité
électorale est aussi un idéal un
humanisme respectueux des libertés
favorable à l'économie de marché est
attentif à la personne comme il y à
table de gauche comme il y à un peuple
de droite
il y a aussi un peuple du centre et
c'est lui que nous représentons
aujourd'hui n'en doutez pas mes chers
amis
notre rassemblement aujourd'hui sera vu
et entendu au delà des frontières du
centre oui je m'adresse à un aussi les
déçus du socialisme et les déçus du
sarkozysme
les déçus du socialisme qui constatent
chaque jour que le monde n'a pas changé
pour le parti socialiste français
aucune inspiration toujours les mêmes
recettes
comme si le monde et la france étaient
restés immobiles et les déçus du
sarkozysme qui ont constaté depuis
quatre ans que la république exemplaire
et irréprochable pour leur avait promis
et rester un voeu de campagne électorale
à tous ces déçus je veux leur dire que
l'alliance est là pour les accueillir
que nous avons besoin d'eux pour bâtir
un projet alternatif
deuxième question qu'allons nous faire
de notre unité
autrement dit pourquoi faisons-nous
cette alliance je vais aller droit au
but
mes chers amis si j'ai décidé de
m'engager dans cette union avec mes amis
du nouveau centre si j'ai accepté que le
nouveau centre sans se dissoudre
car le parti continue à exister
rejoignent une organisation plus large
c'est pour que nous ayons une vraie
chance d'accéder au pouvoir
et je vais vous le dire
je n'ai pas la nostalgie de l'udf
mais j'ai la nostalgie de ses conquêtes
toutes ces grandes villes de france où
nous avions des mères toutes ces régions
et tous ces départements où nous avions
des présidents 1993 où nous avions un
groupe de 200 députés grâce auquel rien
ne se décider sans nous 1974 où l'un des
nôtres est devenu président de la
république pour moderniser la france
cela vous paraît peut-être ambitieux
utopique où il modeste mais nous sommes
là mes chers amis pour gagner
soit on reste dans son coin à commenter
et à donner des leçons à la terre
entière mais alors on renonce à exercer
le pouvoir
ce qui est tout de même gênant quand on
s'affiche comme un responsable politique
c'est l'option bayrou en tout cas en
tout cas en tout cas au moins jusqu'à
ces derniers jours puisque on me dit de
manière assez insistante que les belles
sirènes de l'elysée chantre de plus en
plus fort à l'oreille de notre ulysse du
béarn et que la douce marielle lui
aurait délier la corde qu'il attachait
au mas de sa petite embarcation
j'attends tout de même de voir françois
bayrou nous dire du bien de nicolas
sarkozy lui qui a qualifié dans son
livre d'enfant barbare enfant barbare je
le cite en ce qu'ils se croient tout
puissants qu'ils imaginent que le monde
commence avec lui qu'il est à sa main et
qui détruit des piliers de la république
comme un enfant détruit ses jouets voir
bayrou se rapprocher de nicolas sarkozy
et me dit-on pourquoi pas appelé à voter
pour lui serait tout de même un grand
moment de patinage artistique politique
qui resteraient à coup sûr dans
l'histoire de la vème république
je reprends mon propos mais c'est tout
de même une affaire à suivre donc soit
on reste dans son coin
soit on se dote d'une organisation plus
large et on accepte tout en conservant
notre autonomie quelques compromis pour
se présenter ensemble à des élections et
pour les gagner gagner et à défaut peser
être incontournable aucune majorité sans
nous et nous pour équilibrer modéré
inspiré la modernité nous ne sommes pas
là mes chers amis pour des banquets
républicains
nous ne sommes pas là seulement pour
nous dire que nous partageons les mêmes
convictions
l'alliance ça n'est pas non plus une
écurie présidentielle
c'est une confédération de formation
politique dont l'objectif est de porter
un projet politique alternatif pour les
élections de 2012 oui gagner gagner vous
posez être dans la majorité mais chers
amis n'a pas d'intérêt et surtout de
dignité si on peut si on ne peut pas
appliquer ces cités est en tout cas
celles qui vous sont essentiels et si on
peut discuter de celle de ses
partenaires et pas simplement s'y
soumettre vous voyez le contrat de
législature que nous avons vécu depuis
2007 avec l'ump
c'est pour moi c'est pour moi ça n'est
pas un contrat ça n'est pas un contrat
synallagmatique c'est un contrat
unilatérale dont on n'a pas discuté les
clauses et puisque ce n'est pas un
contrat ça n'est pas non plus une
coalition que nous formons au sein de la
majorité
avions-nous le choix à l'époque en 2007
je ne crois pas c'était cela ou la
disparation du centre et bien moi je ne
veux pas revivre cela
je vais vous dire mes chers amis si nous
voulons si nous avons la ferme volonté
mai 2012 ne ressemblera pas à mai 2007
si nous sommes
second tour nous gagnerons et si nous ne
sommes pas au second tour nous pesons
et ceux qui vous disent et ce qu'ils
nous disent vous avez été au
gouvernement pendant quatre ans et
maintenant vous voulez faire autrement
eh bien je leur réponds c'est justement
parce que nous avons vécu cela pendant
quatre ans que nous ne voulons pas de
cela à l'avenir
pour la france cela veut dire qu'au soir
du premier tour
ce ne sera pas le ralliement des hommes
les uns derrière les autres
un peu comme les bourgeois de calais
aligné en robe de bure
mais le ralliement des idées pour un
contrat de gouvernement une coalition
comme dans toute l'europe une coalition
qui empêche la monarchie républicaine et
l'hyper concentration des pouvoirs
tout ce qui éloigne les français de
leurs gouvernants une coalition qui
empêche l'arbitraire et les fed annonce
nuisible à la crédibilité de l'action
gouvernementale une coalition qui
respecte la diversité de la société
française où chacun se sente un tant
soit peu représentés au sein des
pouvoirs
mes chers amis je le répète nous devons
être ceux qui portons cette idée que la
majorité de second tour se fera sous
forme d'un contrat de gouvernement et
non d'un ralliement des hommes un autre
nous serons nous serons les gardiens et
les garants vigilant de principe
nous serons les gardiens et les garants
vigilant de mesure et de réformes qui
nous semble fondamental pour le pays
ces mesures et ces principes seront
inscrits dans le marbre d'un contrat de
gouvernement
et ce contrat de gouvernement sera à la
condition sinequanone de notre soutien
dans l'hypothèse où nous serions pas au
second tour
je vous livre pour ma part trois ou
quatre principes qui sont pour moi
incontournable pour participer à toute
majorité nouvelle
le premier principe c'est une république
exemplaire et une démocratie nouvelle
une république exemplaire irréprochable
où la politique est à l'abri du monde
des affaires
une démocratie nouvelle qui fait
confiance aux corps intermédiaires aux
fondations aux associations ou
paritarisme pour supporter le changement
le deuxième principe une société qui
donne sa chance à chacun hier mesdames
et messieurs je suis allé au conseil de
classe de mon petit village tranquille
de 1400 habitants en normandie une
équipe enseignante motivés et de qualité
mauvais cru mais savez vous combien
d'enfants de cm2 passant en sixième sans
les acquis fondamentaux lire écrire
compter
l'institutrice cndd 1 une enseignante
d'exception me dit j'ai tout essayé on a
tout essayé on essaie de leur donner
l'envié mais rien n'y fait constat
terrible sur une case de 24 enfants
dix enfants sont en difficulté de
lecture d'écriture et de mathématiques
dix enfants dont le destin est
pratiquement scellé nous serons ce mais
chers amis qui par une transformation de
notre système scolaire porteront l'idée
que l'éducation sera notre première
priorité
notre deuxième priorité notre troisième
priorité et notre ultime priorité
si dans certaines écoles il faut la
maternelle à deux ans car trop de
parents sont des feuillants à leur
mettons là s'il faut des moyens
complémentaires dans les zones urbaines
sensibles ou dans les petits villages de
normandie qui ont des problématiques
différentes et qui impose des solutions
différentes
alors donnons l'autonomie aux
établissements pour leur permettre de
mieux construire leur projet pédagogique
nous devons porter une ambition que 100%
des enfants en cm2 sachent lire écrire
et compter pour empêcher ce terrible
gâchis humain et éviter le gouffre que
nous creusons chaque jour un peu plus
troisième principe une croissance fondée
sur la production
le constat est clair mes chers amis
celui du décrochage de l'économie
française
notre problème ce n'est pas la chine où
ça n'est pas l'inde c'est d'abord notre
contre-performance au sein de l'europe
deux chiffres deux chiffres auraient dû
faire la une des journaux il ya quelques
semaines la france 22 battre le record
de son déficit du commerce extérieur
pendant que l'allemagne à elle seule
affiche est en excédent commercial de 6
milliards d'euros
depuis trente ans nous avons construit
un modèle de croissance basé sur la
consommation financée à crédit
nous devons comme l'ont fait l'allemagne
et les pays-bas construire notre modèle
sur la production et la france je vous
le dis ne restera un grand pays que si
elle bâtit une politique recentrer sur
la reconstruction de son secteur
productif
voilà pourquoi il faut orienter notre
politique en faveur des petites et
moyennes entreprises qui permettront de
créer les quatre millions d'emplois
marchands qui nous manque
quatrième principe l'horizon politique
d'une europe fédérale
la crise de l'euro c'est la crise de
l'or d'une europe mal construites
fédéralisme économique fédéralisme
budgétaire harmonisation fiscale et
sociale budget européen
voilà l'europe que nous voulons plus
d'europe pour plus de france est plus
d'europe pour peser dans le monde voilà
quel devrait être le chantier
prioritaire du président de la
république qui sera élu l'année
prochaine
alors je vous ai cité quatre
orientations politiques il y en a bien
sûr bien d'autres mais après avoir
répondu à ses deux premières questions
je voudrais terminer mon propos par la
troisième question comment allons nous
faire
j'ai en tête trois temps à respecter
engager le dialogue avec les français
pour établir la confiance bâtir notre
projet est mené une campagne d'idées
pour créer une espérance présenter non
seulement une candidature mais une
équipe à la prochaine présidentielle
alors mes chers amis ce dont nous avons
besoin c'est de nous adresser à la
france d oublier à la france de celles
et ceux qui tout en travaillant non plus
n'ont plus d'espoir et je sais que ça ne
sera pas simple car au fond d'eux mêmes
les français ont envie de renverser la
table et ont envie de tout jeter par
dessus bord tous les autres candidats
mes chers amis je romps sur la peur et
donc feront tout pour l'entretenir
nicolas sarkozy et l'ump pour montrer
qu'il faut un chef fort et expérimenté
martine aubry ou françois hollande pour
montrer qu'il faut plus de
fonctionnaires et plus d'assistanat pour
nous protéger
et je ne parle pas de marine le pen ou
de mélenchon unis par l'extrémisme et le
rejet de l'autre
nous nous ne devons pas être comme ces
candidats de la peur pendant cette
campagne nous ne devons pas être
complices de ceux qui veulent réduire au
silence les forces du rêve
c'est même tout l'inversé
entre une droite qui ne jurent que par
l'homme providentiel et une gauche qui
ne jurent que par l'état providence nous
devons incarner l'avenir et la
responsabilité être tout simplement des
militants du possible et des militants
de l'avenir nous devons être les
champions d'une france apaisée mais
certainement pas d'une france bisounours
dans bien des domaines la situation est
grave
trop grave pour faire croire aux
français qu'on sentait qu'on sentira ans
à coups de tables rondes de commissions
théodule et qu'on dirait qu'on réduira
la dette simplement en supprimant trois
voitures de fonction il nous faudra du
courage il nous faudra une ligne de
conduite simple esprit de responsabilité
courage et justice alors mes chers amis
en conclusion ayez confiance dans les
dix prochains mois ils auront à bilan
nous aurons d'abord un projet ils auront
de l'argent nous en nous nous aurons
d'abord du coeur ils ont un chef
nous nous aurons une équipe nous avons
fait le choix de l'unité
nous avons repris le chemin de la maison
commune c'est ce que nous avons démontré
aujourd'hui dit le maintenant autour de
vous il faut que des plaines du nord
jusqu'au massif de provence des dunes de
l'atlantique jusqu'aux forêt de sologne
on sache ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
à epinay que la nation centriste s'est
reformée et qu'elle sera bien présente à
la prochaine élection présidentielle et
qu elle n'y sera pas pour faire de la
figuration mais pour gagner
je remercie
chers amis juste avant la dernière
intervention et parce que vous avez à
peine commencé à profiter de l'apéritif
je le sais bien et que vous attendez la
suite je voudrais quand même saluer
toutes celles et tous ceux qui depuis
plusieurs jours
ils sont plus de 120 bénévoles parce que
c'est pas une société qui va vous
nourrir aujourd'hui travail préparent
mobilise transpire depuis ce matin
beaucoup plus que tout goût autour des
barbecues
vous pouvez les applaudir parce que
nourrir de 1300 personnes
c'est pas rien et ils sont venus pour
faire vivre nos valeurs
je veux évidemment également remercié
tous les élus qui sont ici et vous
permettrez quand même de citer les élus
de seine-saint-denis
vincent capo-canellas ce qu'est le maire
du bourget hervé chevreau quel maire
d'epinay dominique bailly qu'est le
maire de beaux jours et qui s'est marié
hier après-midi et laurent rivoire le
maire de noisy-le-sec
vous voyez que même dans les
départements dits difficiles pour nos
idées
en réalité les idées humanistes et zélé
du centre ça peut fonctionner et bien
maintenant
jacques sosa conseiller général et vous
dire et vous direz je souhaite tout à
l'heure on parlait de groupe
parlementaire je souhaite qu'il puisse y
en avoir dans toutes les assemblées vous
dire qu'en seine-saint-denis pour la
première fois depuis que le conseil
général existe
nous avons un groupe centriste avec des
élus du nouveau centre un élu non
inscrit et un élu du parti radical
on a déjà des groupes commun ça veut
dire qu'on est capable de porter nos
valeurs et nos combats en commun
chers amis voici maintenant le moment
d'accueillir le président du parti
radical qui a été huit ministres de
l'environnement qui a apporté nos
valeurs à la fois sur la rénovation
urbaine sur la cohésion sociale mais
récemment sur l'environnement et qui a
choisi un autre chemin depuis quelques
semaines un chemin qui a permis qu'on se
réunisse tous et surtout qu'on est un
espoir pour 2012
je vous demande d'accueillir jean louis
borloo
alors
vous vous observerez que ce sont ceux
qui sont à l'ombre qui applaudissent
alors ceux qui sont soleil crève de
chaud ah non ce qu'ils sont tous à
l'oeil aussi bien chers amis chers amis
pour un petit déjeuner entre amis pour
un petit banquet républicain qui devait
simplement nous permettent d'échanger
entre nous on avait même prévu qu'il n'y
ait pas d'intervention
vous voyez et bien c'est à mon avis
complètement toute chose aujourd'hui
c'est depuis tout à l'heure mon cher
jean christophe lé le compteur a tourné
puisque on a dépassé les 3000 personnes
sans compter les les centaines et les
milliers de mails qui ne sont pas
revenues de nos amis des pyrénées et
provence de l'île de la réunion de la
guadeloupe et de la martinique parce que
ce n'était pas un s'est dépeint ce n'est
pas un congrès il n'y a pas de vote ya
pas de révolue de résolution c'était une
rencontre un banquet républicain entre
nous mais en même temps notre capacité à
fonder ce nouveau parti politique
l'alliance républicaine écologiste et
sociale elle est fondée ici aujourd'hui
à epinay elle est fondée pas pour une
circonstance particulière
elle est fondée pour les décennies qui
viennent les membres et amis sont
importants l'alliance l'alliance des
hommes et des femmes
l'alliance des républicains l'alliance
de l'écologie l'alliance des enjeux
sociaux
l'alliance de tous les centristes comme
le disait
hervé les deux hervé toutes les familles
centristes à l'exception d'une ou deux
personnalités mais l'alliance est bien
plus que le centre se sont également de
nos amis de droite de cette droite
républicaine de cette droite sociale de
cette droite qui qui veut d'abord
l'action
ce sont des gens de gauche les gens
comme jean marie bockel mais bien
d'autres
des syndicalistes des personnes de la
société civile des associations des gens
qui ne s'étaient jusque là jamais engagé
dans la vie politique c'est sa
l'alliance ça ne peut pas être une
alliance de circonstance de quelques
personnes politiques qui pourraient
s'entendre et ne plus entendre
c'est une force politique qui va c'est
la force politique qui va être non
seulement
l'alternative entre un ps dépassé devant
les enjeux du 21e siècle et une ump qui
s'est rétrécie vers la peur de l'autre
vers un certaine forme de conservatisme
incapable de rentrer dans l'action très
capable de rentrer dans la dénonciation
mais c'est au delà de ça mais c'est bien
plus que ça
la première formation politique de
jeunes de jean diverses que leur et
féminisé et nous devront l'être encore
plus de toute la société de toutes les
couches sociales qui a compris les
enjeux du 21e siècle
et permettez moi d'en dire deux mots
deux mots parce qu'il ya des mensonges
derrière ce qui nous est racontée
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que le monde
change à une vitesse folle
c'est vrai que nous sommes la première
génération qui a conscience que son
modèle économique fondé sur des
ressources finies devait révolutionner
son modèle et sa note famille politique
l'a compris
nous sommes la première génération qui
sait au fond d'elle-même en haut on n'en
parle pas toute la journée
mais qui sait au fond d'elle-même que le
progrès que nos emplois ont été fondés
sur des énergies sûres ainsi modèle
énergétique qui est en difficulté soit
parce qu'ils les fossiles soit parce
qu'il ya une volonté d'évolution et une
volonté de transition énergétique et
pour autant ce ne sont pas des drames
ce sont des opportunités mais nous
savons et notre génération le sait de
même que notre génération connaît
l'accélération prodigieuse de
l'espérance de vie qui fait que nos 40
50 ans sont à la fois à tenir la main de
leurs enfants de leurs jeunes sans être
certains d'ailleurs qu'ils auront un
diplôme et sans être certain que ce
diplôme sera le passeport à un emploi
rapide est qualifié et de l'autre côté
de l'autre côté l'allongement le
troisième âge le quatrième âge les
maladies enfantines et alors cette force
cette france qui travaille cette france
des forces vives est inquiète de devoir
porter c'est une première de l'histoire
de l'humanité
nous n'avons pas encore l'organisation
qui pour pouvoir le faire et puis ils
sentent bien ces français que notre
modèle de diplômes pour le diplôme du
mépris de la valorisation des acquis de
l'expérience de ce modèle de
l'aristocratie même du diplôme que les
mieux formés académique soit même payé
pendant leurs études alors qu'ils feront
les plus grandes carrières mais en même
temps 80 % d'une classe d'âge sans
qualification et une marche entre le
diplôme théorique et l'activité
professionnelle marche infranchissable
etc est une des causes des difficultés
de notre jeunesse est bien cette
génération c'est qu'on a ces
problèmes-là de même qu'elle sait
elle c'est cette génération comme l'a
expliqué hervé tout à l'heure que 20%
des petits d'une case je sais on va me
dire 'c'est ta marotte nous casse les
pieds je m'en fous je continue tant
qu'on n'aura pas réglé cette question
dans chaque classe de 20 ou 25 il y as 1
6 7 4 enfants qui pour une raison
particulière
soit parce qu'ils sont surdoué en sur
nrj parce qu'il ya des problèmes de
langue parce qu'il est dyslexique bref
des problèmes urbains des problèmes
familiaux des problèmes de santé
publique décroche d'un modèle forme
était pour les 80%
la maîtresse plus rien faire c'est pas
un problème de pro seule c'est tout le
village c'est toute la société qui doit
tout faire pour que chacune de ces
pépites trouve son rythme et sa place
dans la société française
car si on ne le fait pas mais à mais
d'abord on se prit de l'essentiel d'un
moteur de croissance
mais si on ne le fait pas c'est la
tension et la violence c'est l'échec
scolaire le désespoir et le refus de la
société de ses codes
c'est de là que naît que naît la
violence que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui qui inquiète la société
française et puis et puis les français
le savent
nous sommes la première génération à
savoir que le problème de l'endettement
public
c'est à dire la capacité à financer
l'action collective
nous sommes la première génération à
savoir que ce n'est pas un problème
comptable que ce n'est pas un problème
de techno que ce n'est pas un problème
technique y regarde nos amis grecs y
voit que c'est un problème de société un
problème politique
il voit bien quels sont les efforts
insurmontable dans sa vitesse qui est
demandé au peuple grec
et les français savent pertinemment qu'à
80 % de déficit 90% dans les deux ans
qui viennent
si on n'y prend garde c
le destin notre destin qui nous
échappera définitivement et puis pour
terminer c'est la première génération
la première qui a un problème aussi
grave pour avoir un nid un endroit pour
s'épanouir pour forger la famille ça
s'appelle un logement ça fait 35 ans que
nous sommes dans une crise du logement
en quinze ans le logement était pliée
par 2,5 pour cent on est passé de 18 à
30 % des revenus du foyer
c'est la plus grande attaque contre eux
le pouvoir d'achat mais c'est aussi des
logements pas adapté trop grand trop
petit trop loin du boulot pas de
déménagement plus de difficultés à
trouver du travail bref
et alors vous savez quelle est la
réponse qu'on nous fait c'est la
mondialisation
voilà la réponse que nous entendons des
uns des autres
la réponse à tout ça c'est la peur de
l'autre c'est les frontières c'est
l'euro cessé l'autre c'est l'étranger
celles immigrés c'est le cancer de
l'assistanat c'est sûr fermement alors
je vais vous le dire comme je le pense
oui il y à des sujets de mondialisation
oui il faut s'organiser
oui il faut une taxe carbone européenne
oui il faut des champions européens oui
c'est aussi de l'espoir car les sujets
du monde c'est l'énergie l'eau les
déchets l'agriculture et les transports
qui sont les cinq pôles de génie
français c'est aussi ça la
mondialisation mais jaune mais je ne
laisserai pas dire nous n'avons pas le
droit de laisser dire que les problèmes
de logement sont liés à la
mondialisation et sont liées à
l'immigration
un pays qui a la plus faible densité en
europe qui a les meilleurs ouvrier maçon
architectes
n'est pas capable de sortir de cette
crise pendant 30 ans par désinvolture
par une organisation
on a laissé ce pays construire moins de
320 milles logements par an alors qu'il
en faut 500 milles pendant vingt ans que
ça nous savons le faire
c'est un problème de méthode c'est un
problème d'organisation
comme c'est un problème de méthode pour
avoir 100% des enfants qu'ils sachent
lire écrire et compter
oui
oui c'est un problème de méthode c'est
un problème de méthode pour arrêter de
faire l'aristocratie des diplô mé pour
avoir 100% deux jeunes français
qualifiés oui c'est un problème de
méthode de permettre un accès à la
justice plus hein c'est pas les
magistrats qui sont en cause on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler
les uns et les autres oui il faudra
réindustraliser hervé on en a pas en a
parlé et on aura un grand problème
économique mais qu'est ce qui me permet
de vous dire tout ça
qu'est ce qui me permet de vous dire
qu'on peut passer à l'action et résoudre
les quelques problèmes fondamentaux qui
dépendent que de nous pas des canadiens
pas des américains pas des chinois
pasdeloup en c2 nous le logement le
pouvoir d'achat l'emploi et l'éducation
qu'est ce qui me permet de vous le dire
eh ben je vais vous dire ce qui me
permet de vous le dire et vous
l'affirmez parce qu'il ya 20 ans des des
fous furieux des valenciennois sont
venus chercher un jeune avocat ce
valenciennois qui avait connu le plus
grand désastre économique et social
40000 licenciement je vais pas vous
raconter l'histoire je vais juste vous
dire une chose
j'ai compris là au bout d'un certain
temps que quand on réunit la cgt le
patronat la cfdt et fo
les agriculteurs et les industriels les
chambres de métiers et les chambres de
commerce
la fonction publique et la fonction
privée lorsqu'on réunissait les
associations les gens engagés les
généraux les vieux les jeunes les
universités les propres quand on avait
un projet pour un territoire
eh bien on pouvait changer le destin à
condition d'avoir une méthode à
condition d'avoir un cadre clair à
condition d'avoir une équipe et à
conduction avoir du respect
mais qu'est ce qui me permet de vous le
dire également ce qui me permet de vous
le dire également c'est parce que nous
sommes ici chez notre avis chevreau un
des plans de rénovation urbaine un mot
simplement il ya dix ans souvenez vous
la honte de la france la honte des
logements insalubres de la dégradation
urbaine des équipements publics
explosent et est brûlé dans ses 450
quartier français on avait tout essayé
avait-on dit on avait tout essayé on en
était revenu au coup de peinture de la
cage d'escalier de michel rocard
eh bien ce n'est pas vrai on s'est
révoltés on a refusé cette situation et
tous ensemble avec les maires les
syndicats le 1 % l'europe l'état la
caisse des dépôts les villes et les
régions
on a lancé le chantier du siècle on l'a
bien lancer ce chantier de 40 milliards
qui a changé la vie de deux ou trois
millions de personnes et aujourd'hui
dans quelques minutes mes amis à 15
heures exactement à mot les trois
dernières tours de la pierre collinet
voix de foudroyer symbole d'achèvement
d'apprendre de rénovation urbaine qui
était prétendument impossible moi je
vous le dit
oui en 2005 on m'a confié l'emploi la
bataille de l'emploi vous savez on avait
dépassé les 19 2% et on nous avait
expliqué que c'était le plombier
polonais qui venait prendre le travail
du français vous souvenez de ça on m'a
donné ça qu'est ce qu'on a fait pareil
la méthode les syndicats tout le monde
services à la personne apprentissage on
reçoit les demandeurs d'emploi
tendrement gentiment on les informe les
orienteront les ailes on les soutient
bref 10,2 7,2 en deux ans et demi
il ya même une polémique est-ce qu'on
n'aurait pas maintenant truqué les
chiffres du chômage ce que je veux vous
dire c'est qu'on peut faire tout ça
j'essaie fort et au fond du pont
pourquoi moi je sors de mes gros
pourquoi je veux qu'on se mette à notre
compte
car j'en ai assez dans la politique de
la dénonciation de l'autre
j'en ai assez de l'appeler tes
spectacles
j'en ai assez qu'on essaie de
caricaturer de s'inventer des querelles
politiques gauche et droit alors nous
avons une obligation tout simplement
d'action d'action immédiat d'action
concret je vais vous dire si nous
faisons tout ça si nous débattons de
tout ça pendant cette période là et
après croyez moi les extrêmes et
notamment le front national qui se
trompe et sur le diagnostic
le drame c'est pas l'autre et sur la
solution
le repli sur soi qui serait dramatique
catastrophique pour les plus pauvres de
la société française et pour les plus
fragiles
et bien c'est nous les forces anti front
national pas parce qu'on les méprise pas
scoré pauvres français
on répondra par l'action j'en ai assez
j'en ai assez de cette politique du
verbe de cette espèce de mépris
ils ont travaillé avec chirac sarkozy
on aurait donc pas d'idées pas d'opinion
pas de bilan
pas de force en réalité ils n'ont pas de
force eux la vérité la vérité c'est que
la gauche et la droite est honorable
elle est épuisée annales plus le sens de
l'action et elle ne comprend pas le 21e
siècle c'est ça la vérité
alors mes amis les choses sont
maintenant assez simple oui
hervé hervé jean marie bockel ont dit
oui on est bien plus que la course
acquis plus centriste que moi tu meurs
ça s'est tellement grotesque et ridicule
je vais vous dire je vais vous dire nous
sommes la force qui va mener la france
et je vais vous dire pourquoi parce que
nous sommes à la fois là les élus les
les fous de l'action de la vraie action
concrète
ce qui est bien c'est ce qui marche
devant les problèmes à réseau et en même
temps nous avons un cap une vision et
des valeurs et des attitudes oui nous
sommes différents oui nous sommes les
héritiers de la famille de simone veil
de du droit de vote à 18 ans de la
décentralisation de la loi de cohésion
sociale dans l'installation de la haute
autorité de lutte contre les
discriminations oui nous sommes les
promoteurs de ce chantier du siècle dans
nos quartiers le veulent oui nous sommes
tout ça et c'est pas parce que nous
avons cru pour certains à l'ump à son
espoir à cette promesse que nous allons
continuer nous taire
mais ça ne nous empêchera pas de saluer
ce qui a été fait on nomme entraînera
pas sur ce déni la wii nicolas sarkozy a
fait reculer le front national en 2007
comme personne
oui je peux dire et affirmer que
l'autonomie des universités c'est une
bonne chose
oui fallait faire c'est très difficile
réforme des retraites et bien d'autres
choses mais c'est une
belle séquence qui s'ouvre c'est une
nouvelle ère et vous savez nous allons
gagner car nous semble l'avant de
transformation économique écologique
social et républicain de notre pays
alors mes amis cette force dans chaque
commune dans chaque département dans
chaque région
j'appelle la jeunesse appelle les
ouvriers les problèmes à nous rejoindre
nous avons besoin des uns et des autres
mais mes amis
cette force qui va cette force qui est
là pour 20 et 30 ans qui n'est pas une
écurie présidentielle doit avoir
évidemment un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle d'abord
et je vais vous dire pourquoi je vais
vous dire par quoi parce que la force
anti 21 avril c'est nous parce que si on
laissait car si on laissait s'affronter
le vainqueur de la primaire entre
énarques du parti socialiste et l'ump
actuelle les visions classiques de notre
société
je vous garantis que le front national
serait même en tête du premier tour
nous sommes les véritables forces du
camp anti front national c'est nous
c'est pas à eux
nous sommes le rassemblement est pas la
division
alors je dis à nos amis de l'ump venu
débattre avec nous et venez nous
soutenir car beaucoup d'entre eux
imaginez-vous sont tentés alors oui il
ya une échéance présidentielle
nous avons toujours donné notre
calendrier entre l'été et l'automne à
calendrier ça se respecte et mes amis je
vais répondre aux questions qui ont été
posées le calendrier je ne le changerai
pas se préparer ce n'est pas hésiter
c'est respecter les français